josh lindbloom this is start number
three looking for win number two here
tonight yeah pick the winners last time
out against a white sox
one down here's polanco
[Applause]
get a long way to right field deep to
the corner and go on a home run
jorge polanco tees off on the first
pitch from lin bloom and hits his second
home run of the year
rosario crushing his fourth career grand
slam last night
and the one old pitch is swinging a fly
ball into right that's it pretty well
gamble back on the track at the wall
jumps up and that's gone
just out of gamel's reach to right and
rosario adds on
his fifth home run make it two-nothing
twins here in the opening inning corey
lynn bloom has tried to come in twice to
the left-handed hitters and polanco made
him pay for it right there
rosario made him pay for it the opener
in tonight's game is tyler clifford
it'll be his sixth career appearance as
an opener his 14th start overall
council has rearranged his batting order
tonight avi garcia will lead off first
time he's at lead off this year
and garcia turns on one that is way back
and way gone
abby garcia with a lead off home run
here in the first inning yeah work pays
off doesn't it we highlighted that when
we came on the air the extra work that
he and andy haynes
did on the tee and the soft toss
boy what a nice swing for abby garcia
his first
home run as a brewer
breaking ball got him good one good
depth to that slider there
i don't know if there was a cat and
mouse as to who's starting who's not
and the one-two swag of the missy got
him on a breaking ball so back-to-back
stacia strikeouts
as that one disappeared down to the
weight
garber drops to a knee kicks out his
left leg and the 1-2 swag and a miss and
down he goes and stachak indeed strikes
out the side
rosario will
hit next for the twins he's already hit
a home run today
oh my high fly right field going back as
gamel there's another one for rosario
his third of the series
a two run home run and it's four to one
that's why i always say eddie rosario is
just a tough guy to pitch to eddie
just hammers this thing spin cycle
slider that stays up and he just can
really
get his hands and barrel of the bat to
the ball he's driven in seven runs in
the series rosario with three swings of
the bat
rolls over this one got to get over
claudio flip it oh nice play yeah
flips it to claudia covering very nice
good job by jerko to flip it out of that
glove i mean a lot of bad things can
happen you're trying to do that with the
first baseman's mid maybe in the webbing
you flip it straight up but claudio's
sticking right with it able to make the
catch
and getting to the bag first that was
beautiful
got to improvise every now and again
and here is manny pina standing in
opening pitch in the bottom half of
inning number five and manny pina smacks
one in the left center and deep warning
track get up get out of here and gone
for manny
pina and it's a four to two game
manny pina goes out of here that's his
first of the year
into the brewers bullpen i should say
formerly the brewers bullpen
still can't get used to that switch
they're out in right field now but pina
just put another one on the board for
the crew
it's 4-2
minnesota
solo home run last inning to start the
inning
he swings 3-0 he launches one into right
center field and it is gone
the pineapple strikes again
we are tied at four
that was a frozen rope down to right
center my goodness three and oh took
advantage of it
well you'd love to see that
swinging three and oh you get a pitch
exactly where you're looking for it
driving it out of the ballpark a lot of
managers will save their closer as the
road team for the bottom of the ninth
inning if it comes up yell at start of
the season one for 27. he's turned it
around he's seeing the ball better seven
hits in his last seven games including
three home runs
four four tie bottom of the eighth
rogers deals yell it's chops one that's
fair the shift was on
and yelled is gonna head to second base
throw comes in yelich is down and yelich
is in there oh you love that
a hustle double for christian yelich
and you knew he was gonna be able to get
into second base
all right jed jerko now go ahead run at
second base and the speedy yelich
the 1-0 jerko in the air center field
back on it is buxton
near the wall he leaped and she's gone
jed jericho
a towering home run to center
two-run blast the brewers have the lead
in the eighth
[Applause]
well he knew he got good wood on it just
questioned that he'd get under it too
much to leave the ballpark but it did
not just kept going
oh and two here he comes and a swing and
a mess he struck him out the brewers win
tonight
josh hader closes the door for his third
save